mesdames messieurs vous qui êtes
physiquement présence maintenant au
Sénat et puis ceux qui sont en
visioconférence bienvenue
je suis heureux avec Nadine belureau et
Jérôme Durand vous accueillir ce matin
pour vous présenter le rapport qu'ils
ont produit et que la commission des
lois a voté à l'unanimité hier sur la
police judiciaire je rappelle que
au mois de septembre dernier avait été
annoncé par le ministre de l'Intérieur
une modification de l'organisation de la
police nationale une façon générale et
tout particulièrement sur le point de la
police judiciaire une émotion s'est fait
s'est fait connaître une émotion assez
vive d'abord évidemment des services de
police et puis ensuite singulièrement de
ceux qui s'occupent de préjudiciaire et
puis aussi d'une partie de
l'administrature pas dans sa totalité
mais y compris par la voix du rockeur
général Mollens faisant état de ses
réserves sur l'organisation qui était
proposée
nous avons face à cette situation
décidée à la commission des lois comme
nous le faisons habituellement j'ai les
presque dire que nous sommes les
créateurs de nos propres moyens
d'investigation
décidé cette mission confiée comme il
est d'usage en la matière au sein de
commission mais c'est vrai aussi dans
les autres commissions de façon
transpartisane les élus de groupe issus
de groupes politiques différents et en
l'occurrence de majorité d'opposition
pour être parfaitement clair l'objectif
étant de pouvoir établir à l'état des
lieux de vérité et puis de trouver les
moyens de proposition
partagées bien évidemment cela a permis
de constater que les inquiétudes étaient
bien réelles qu'il y avait un
contestablement un besoin de discussion
de la part avec les services bien
évidemment et de mieux comprendre ce qui
était annoncé par le ministre tout en
comprenant finalement qu'au bout du
compte ce qui était annoncé pour se
mettre en place très très vite n'allait
pas aussi rapidement ce sera pas aussi
rapidement fait puis dire et que donc
nous avons bien fait de le faire là nous
ne sont pas les seuls faut reconnaître
qu'après nous est venu l'Assemblée
nationale
pour dire on va faire aussi notre
mission ils ont déjà rendu leur rapport
et puis il y a eu surtout de façon sans
dénigrer les collègues de l'Assemblée le
rapport des trois le rapport unique des
trois services d'inspection qui est venu
ce qui nous a permis finalement
peut-être de clôturer la séquence si je
puis dire et en essayant d'être à la
fois dans le constat partagé de ce que
des rapporteurs ont fait puis en même
temps d'autres capacité de proposer des
choses environ 22 il faut pas environ 22
propositions sont faites au terme de ce
rapport dernier point que je voudrais
évoquer devant vous c'est que
le constat évidemment c'est de la police
nationale fonctionne en silo que
les savent plusieurs services exercent
des missions de police judiciaire qui en
réalité ne correspondent plus ça c'est
de partager à la criminalité
d'aujourd'hui en tous les cas la manière
de pouvoir lutter contre celle-ci et
puis
force est de constater que la police
judiciaire n'attire plus et qu'au sein
des services de police s'engager dans la
préjudiciaire c'est pas aussi évident
qu'on pourrait l'imaginer parce que pour
plein de raisons d'évolution de la
société de temps à consacrer de capacité
peut-être aussi pour pour agir et c'est
donc un sujet qui est tout aussi
important que que le reste voilà nous
rapporteurs les rapports de la
commission auditionnée plus de 120
personnes
ont aussi effectué des déplacements de
terrain j'imagine qui vous le diront
elle leur rapport qui a été présenté
hier nous aurait dit qu'il a fait
l'unanimité de la commission ce n'est
pas tout à fait neutre tout de même
fait 22 propositions voilà je vais pas
aller plus long que cela je vais laisser
la parole peut-être Nadine bellerault en
premier ou Jérôme du Rhin je sais pas
faites comme vous le souhaitez pour
rentrer dans le détail de leur
proposition merci à vous
merci beaucoup bonjour à toutes et à
tous et puis merci d'être présent ici ou
en visio avec mon collègue Jérôme Durin
je voudrais d'abord
vous dire et nous souhaitions on va
parler ensemble et à devoir on va faire
un
binôme jusqu'au bout de la présentation
de cette mission
je voudrais commencer par vous dire que
comme l'a dit le président nous avons
fait un constat partagé d'ailleurs
partagé entre nous et partager
d'ailleurs aussi avec les autres
missions puisque grosso modo nous nous
retrouvons sur sur la réalité
aujourd'hui de la police nationale et
nous avons fait au Sénat comme l'a dit
le président nous avons pu faire à
partir de ce constat partagé des
propositions communes qui ont été
adoptées à l'unanimité de notre
commission et c'est vrai qu'il faut le
souligner en effet l'été dernier pour
resituer un peu et revenir un peu
ce qui a été dit est bien dit par
président l'été dernier en 2022 il y a
eu des contestations à l'occasion de la
réforme de la police nationale c'est
contestations d'abord évidemment été
tout de suite relayée par la police
judiciaire qui s'est senti un peu écarté
de cette réorganisation et ensuite
relayé comme vous le savez tous par les
magistrats et tous les magistrats donc
nous nous on s'est donné comme objectif
en fait avec cette mission de pouvoir
évaluer donc la pertinence de
l'organisation qui était proposée la
pertinence de l'organisation actuelle ce
qui pouvait être proposé et de pouvoir
nous positionner sur cette réforme nous
avons donc ça a été rappelé en effet
président et avec Jérôme on est
auditionné 120 personnes on a réalisé
deux déplacements sur les 8 départements
qui sont expérimentés nous avons
auditionné toutes les évidemment ces
expérimentations si nous ne sommes pas
rendus sur place ainsi que les
territoires ou
ultramarins ou la réforme est mise en
oeuvre
cela nous a permis donc de dresser
différents constats c'est ce que je
ferais avant de passer la parole à
Jérôme tout d'abord en effet la
l'organisation des missions judiciaires
dans la police nationale on nous l'avons
déjà dit ça ne répond plus aux enjeux
actuels de la criminalité ça c'est
quelque chose qui était assez frappant
en effet nous assistons aujourd'hui à
l'émergence de nouvelles formes de
criminalité et marquée par un lien très
fort entre délinquance locale et trafic
d'envergure international et cette
nouvelle forme de criminalité d'ailleurs
été très bien relaté par le service le
sirasco qui est le service qui s'occupe
d'informations qui s'occupent de la
grande criminalité qui qualifie
actuellement d'ailleurs maintenant de
néobankitisme il s'agit je le cite d'un
banditisme nouveau ici de cités
sensibles se différencient d'un milieu
traditionnel fort affaibli par succès
des investigations politiques policières
et un changement de génération ce grand
bain titisme écrit organisé trouve
également leur source dans la petite et
moyenne délinquance ainsi que dans le
trafic de stupéfiants donc c'est une
donnée importante pour pouvoir réfléchir
à cette réforme que cette nouvelle forme
de criminalité organisée qui je le
signale et de plus en plus en effet
violente et je le répète ce lien entre
délinquance locale et grande criminalité
et très très important et très imprégné
dans notre société or l'exercice de la
police judiciaire aujourd'hui par
rapport à cette évolution comme vous le
savez est séparé la police nationale en
deux directions vous avez une Direction
de la Sécurité publique qui traite près
de 98% de la délinquance et la petite et
moyenne délinquance et puis vous avez la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire celle qui a manifesté
beaucoup d'inquiétudes qui elle est
spécialisée en charge de la lutte contre
la criminité organisée la
cybercriminalité le terrorisme les
formes graves et complexes de
criminalité ces deux directions
disposent d'une grande autonomie de
fonctionnement aujourd'hui chacune
dentelle rencontre en pratique à sa
direction et on est obligé de constater
qu'il y a un manque d'interaction entre
ces services au niveau local qui pèse
sur les fissu sciences de l'action de la
police nationale à cela s'ajoute comme
cela aussi a été dit il y a une perte
d'activité croissante de la filière
judiciaire dans la police nationale ça
c'est un vrai sujet les causes de celle
des affection se désamour de la police
judiciaire sont multiples vous savez que
la complexification de la procédure
pénale est un vrai sujet cela entraîne
aussi une forte responsabilisation
personnelle des agents des enquêteurs
qui ont un sentiment d'insécurité il
suffit d'un retard dans une procédure il
y a donc des responsabilités
administratives ou à pénale de l'agent
qui peut peser lourdement sur son
activité il y a aussi une déception il
faut le dire devant les décisions
rendues par les tribunaux et une sorte
de oui déception par rapport à
l'investissement qui a pu être réalisé
par les enquêteurs il y a aussi les
cycles horaires et les régimes
indemnitaires qui sont moins favorables
pour cette filière indigouragement aussi
depuis quelques années face aussi à une
priorité qui certes peut tout à fait se
comprendre il s'agit pas pour nous de
remettre en cause la présence sur le
terrain des policiers sur la voie
publique mais il y a quand même une
priorité affichée depuis quelques années
en faveur des services de la voie
publique au détriment de ceux de
l'investigation puisque l'idée étant de
mettre davantage de bleu sur le terrain
tout ça se combine s'entretient avec un
phénomène qui alors là avec Jérôme on a
on était on savait qu'il y avait un
engorgement très important des
procédures mais il faut dire que ça nous
a été rappelé à pratiquement toutes nos
interventions qu'elles soient polissues
ou magistrats et il y a un stock de
procédure extrêmement important
je dirais qu'important il m'a un peu
faible puisque nous sommes à plus de 2
millions 600 000 procédures qui sont en
stock et qui concernent aussi bien des
contentieux de masques des infractions
délictuelles et criminelles graves donc
évidemment ça ça entraîne de façon
constante la qualité des procédures les
délais de traitement et évidemment les
attentes des justiciers ce qui est quand
même assez dommageable pour l'image à la
fois de notre justice et de notre
sécurité et qui entraîne des modalités
de traitement évidemment dégradées
puisque si on va sur site pour pour
classer on peut pas dire forcément que
c'est un traitement de la justice qui
est la plus la plus satisfaisante voilà
je passe la parole à mon collègue pour
vous présenter deux autres parties
de notre mission avant de reprendre la
parole merci chers collègues bonjour à
tous ma collègue Nadine beluro vient de
vous dépeindre un contexte difficile
pour la police contexte que nous
connaissons tous bien alors je sais que
certains peuvent s'interroger dans les
rangs des journalistes sur les apports
de notre rapport on comparaison des
trois rapports précédents déjà ça permet
de pointer la réalité de la mobilisation
sur ce sujet qui ne faiblit pas alors la
douée partie la fronde l'anpj
reporte sa manifestation prévue le 11
mars parce qu'elle craint de ne pas
pouvoir acheminer c'est ces troupes à
Paris pourtant d'autres actions sont
prévues donc la fronde perdure je
reviens au cœur de mon propos et la
difficile réception de la réforme de la
police nationale sur le terrain
cette réforme poursuit pourtant deux
objectifs qui auraient pu être mieux
perçus une organisation filière au
niveau national permettant l'unification
des missions d'investigation au sein
d'une seule et même direction et au
niveau de la cale la création de
direction départementale de la police
nationale les fameuses ddpn rassemblant
l'ensemble des filières métiers de la
police nationale dans une seule et même
entité et sous une seule et même
autorité les filières nationales ont été
plutôt bien reçus par la base les ddpn
beaucoup moins alors en ce qui nous
concerne les principales critiques que
nous adressons tiennent d'abord à la
méthode poursuivie dans ce projet de
réorganisation un projet qui a consisté
en une expérimentation de ce nouveau
schéma d'organisation dans plusieurs
territoires d'outre-mer et dans 8
départements hexagonaux trois années se
sont écoulées depuis le lancement des
premières expérimentations mais il
s'avère extrêmement difficile dans
l'établir un bilan nous nous y sommes
pourtant à clé
quelques points de satisfaction émergent
l'indéniablement s'agissant notamment
des directions mises en place dans les
territoires ultramarins s'agissant des
expérimentations mises en oeuvre dans
l'Hexagone les résultats sont bien plus
hétérogènes alors si de véritables gains
organisationnels et opérationnels
peuvent être décelés dans certains
départements en particulier en savoir
vous le verrez la page 53 de notre
rapport nombre de direction
départementale de la police nationale
s'apparente davantage à des coquilles
vides dont la mise en place n'a eu aucun
effet sur les pratiques existantes
s'agissant maintenant du projet des
généralisations je pense que nous
pouvons nous accorder sur le fait qu'il
a été particulièrement mal conduit le
manque de concertation et de
communication ont directement alimenter
les doutes autour d'un projet lui-même
inabouti au contour flou et changeant
une de nos difficultés avec un
rapporteur c'est qu'on a travaillé
beaucoup dans le registre de l'oralité
et que finalement on n'avait pas de
support écrit
des choses qui ont constamment changé
évoluer parfois au fil même de nos
travaux le projet a ainsi ressembler à
une succession d'ajustements en réaction
contestation sans stratégie claire ni
calendrier prédéterminé le projet de
départementalisation c'est donc
progressivement imposé comme un sujet
incontournable dans l'agenda politique
et médiatique ce qui est obligé le
ministre de l'Intérieur à l'ancienne
mission d'audit afin de disposer d'une
évaluation des expérimentations mission
qui n'était d'ailleurs pas prévue à
l'origine et à différer la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme pour attendre les
conclusions de notre mission
d'information et de celle de nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale je
dois d'ailleurs confier que je pensais
personnellement que ces quelques mois
auraient permis aux ministres de
l'intérieur de renouer le fil le
dialogue avec les péjistes je crois
constater que ça n'est pas forcément le
cas
alors après avoir entendu 120 personnes
nous avons pu nous faire une idée
éclairée de ce que voulu être la réforme
cela n'a pas été simple les personnes en
charge ne sont pas toujours spécialement
aidés et nous avons parfois découvert
dans la presse je le disais des éléments
qui nous étaient pas dit en audition
deux jours plus tôt il nous semble que
la réforme envisagée de la police
nationale est en réalité une réforme de
la gouvernance de la police nationale
plus que de l'institution elle-même son
enjeu
personnel des représentants de la
filière au niveau territorial supérieur
notamment au niveau zonal les
prérogatives et moyens de chacun devront
être clarifiés le troisième enjeu et le
fait que l'organisation territoriale qui
sera retenue devra permettre de
continuer à traiter de l'ensemble du
spectre de la criminalité il nous semble
que l'organisation la plus pertinente
pourrait se faire en trois niveaux un
niveau national chargé de définir la
doctrine d'emploi d'assurer la
coordination des services de police
judiciaire et de conduire les enquêtes
s'agissant des faits les plus complexes
nécessitant l'intervention des offices
centraux ou la coordination d'un grand
nombre de services sur l'ensemble du
territoire national un niveau zonal
disposant d'une autorité sur les
services de police judiciaire
départementaux afin d'assurer la
coordination de leurs actions est
chargée de traiter la criminalité
organisée complexe ou présentant une
particulière gravité notamment grâce à
l'implantation d'antenne des offices
centraux cet échelon devra disposer de
moyens humains et budgétaires
pour réaliser ces missions un niveau
départemental enfin où l'organisation en
trois niveaux des services de police
judiciaire retenus dans les territoires
ultramarins devra être généralisé pour
ce faire le caractère interdépartemental
des services traitant la criminalité la
plus complexe devra être préservée et un
service traitant de la criminalité
intermédiaire devra être généralisée
dans l'ensemble des départements vous
trouverez beaucoup de propositions liées
à ces deux enjeux que je viens de vous
détailler dans la partie garantir le
traitement de l'ensemble du spectre de
la criminalité par la police nationale
nous sommes par contre convaincus que la
généralisation des ddpn avant la fin de
l'année 2023 nenni réaliste ni
raisonnable les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour conduire sereinement la
réforme dans le respect du calendrier
annoncé par le ministre de l'Intérieur
devant notre commission le 14 février
dernier c'est pourquoi sans remettre en
cause le bien fondé de la réforme et ses
gains potentiels sur laquelle madame
bellureaux et moi-même avons par
ailleurs ce qui nous a pas empêché
d'avoir un rapport commun il nous semble
impératif de le soumettre un véritable
moratoire jusqu'à la fin des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 cela
semble prudent plus prudent si l'on
prend en considération les risques
maintes fois soulignés par le ministère
de l'Intérieur lié à l'organisation de
la Coupe du monde et de Paris 2024 il y
a aussi un contexte général de mutation
de la criminalité dans notre pays ça a
été rappelé par Nadine beluro nous avons
à l'esprit ce qui peut arriver dans des
pays voisins je pense à la Belgique au
Pays-Bas pour voir ce qui pourrait nous
arriver à nous aussi si nous
affaiblissions trop durement notre
système de Belgique judiciaire donc le
moratoire la voie du moratoire doit nous
permettre de pousser à la limitation de
ces risques on peut estimer qu'il est
plus sage de ne pas prendre le risque
désorganisé notre appareil sécuritaire
dans la période à dire vrai en proposant
cela nous proposons finalement une sorte
de porte de sortie honorable au ministre
de l'Intérieur qui est toujours possible
d'ouvrir la grogne même si elle est
moins visible je le répète est toujours
présente chez les péchistes le temps du
moratoire il doit être utile il pourrait
être mis à profit pour mener plusieurs
chantiers que vous trouverez dans les
propositions de la partie sur la voie du
moratoire en premier lieu lancer de
véritables préfigurations et non plus
des expérimentations dans l'Hexagone ce
qui a été fait c'est à droit constant et
ça beaucoup limité l'impact de ces
expérimentations vous verrez à la
lecture du rapport que les
expérimentateurs ont fait un peu ce
qu'il pouvait et on ne souhaite pas
d'ailleurs leur imputer les difficultés
ou les accablées parce que finalement
c'est le contexte et les contraintes qui
l'auront été faites en second lieu il
est nécessaire d'avancer en temps masqué
pour poser les jalons indispensables à
la réussite de la réforme ni la
modification de près de 180 textes
réglementaires ni la mise en cohérence
de l'architecture numérique des
applications de la police nationale avec
sa nouvelle organisation ni la mise en
place de regroupements immobiliers ne
peuvent se faire du jour au lendemain je
crois avoir d'ailleurs compris que
c'était le message que faisait passer le
ministre ou syndicat la semaine dernière
afin de ne pas reproduire les erreurs
passées et de renouer un dialogue qui
nous a semblé rompu il sera également
utile et ce serait encore mieux si le
garde des sceaux décider de s'impliquer
davantage de ce dossier et de ne pas
laisser monsieur Darmanin solo front de
profiter de ce délai pour conduire une
concertation continue et sincère tant au
niveau local que national tantôt prêt
des policiers que des magistrats nous
avons eu de nombreuses remontées de
magistrats qui n'avaient pas été mis au
courant des équipements et qui
d'ailleurs n'en avait même pas constaté
les effets je prends la parole
reste avec moi
oui alors suite à ces propositions je
reviens sur une constatation qui a été
faite donc on vous a parlé sur les
stocks cette réforme nationale je vous
l'ai dit a été le révélateur de cette
situation puisque les personnels de
services de police judiciaire comme vous
le savez craignait d'être embauché pour
gérer ses stocks pour résorber ces
stocks accumulés dans les services de la
sécurité publique c'était une de leurs
craintes une de ces orientations nous
disons clairement serait évidemment
totalement déraisonnable bien sûr
inefficace et puis serait de toute façon
totalement préjudiciable aussi à nos
concitoyens c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle que nous proposons également
que soit bien rééquilibré les effectifs
entre voies publiques et investigation
c'est absolument indispensable dans le
cadre de cette réforme et c'est
d'ailleurs une occasion rêvée puisque
nous proposons que dans la préfiguration
on ne reste pas à droit constant et que
dans les 8 départements qui peuvent être
prises pour cette préfiguration et bien
à ce moment là il y a des moyens il y a
des moyens humains des moyens matériels
pour permettre on va dire à échelle
réelle cette réforme nous souhaitons
donc un doublement des effectifs vous
savez a été demandé un doublement des
effectifs sur la voie publique mais nous
disons et nous répétons que ces
effectifs il faut également les
augmenter à proportion en matière de
investigation sinon cette chaîne pénale
comme vous le savez continuera à être
engorgée il n'y aura pas d'amélioration
dans la respons dans la réponse pénale
ce que nous disons souvent avec Jérôme
c'est vrai qu'il est très important de
pouvoir arrêter le délinquant qui est en
bas de son immeuble ou qui est proche de
votre habitation ou de vos lieux mais à
côté de ça il faut aussi permettait
l'expression arrêter les gros bonnets
donc il ne faut pas couper cette cette
police en deux mais bien le contraire il
faut lui donner les moyens de pouvoir
investiguer au niveau le plus haut ce
qu'on appelle le spectre le plus haut
nous considérons également que la
réforme à la création d'une filière
judiciaire unifiée c'est une opportunité
bien au contraire nous nous pensons
vraiment certains ont pu y voir quelques
inquiétudes mais nous à l'issue de nos
auditions on constitue on considère que
c'est une opportunité si elle est saisie
elle va permettre au personnel qu'il la
composent de véritables parcours de
formation de carrière d'évolution et
d'avancement si cette si cette réforme
pouvait initier ce genre de de
situations dans la police c'est vraiment
pour la police judiciaire une
opportunité on le répète pour qu'elles
puissent se continuer à être aussi
attractive
c'est aussi l'occasion de rappeler et de
garantir le respect des prérogatives de
l'autorité judiciaire donc là on va
plutôt sur le côté à la fois judiciaire
et police le procureur de la République
vous le savez en charge de la mise en
oeuvre de la politique pénale dans son
ressort or la définition des priorités
assignées par les parquets au service
bancaire parfois nous l'avons vu à celle
définie par le préfet au service de la
voie publique il convient donc de bien
rétablir les procureurs de la République
dans le rôle de décisionnaire en
demandant préfet d'ajuster ses
orientations en fonction de la
définition des priorités de politique
pénale sur un territoire donc il faut il
existe dans certains cas un dialogue
mais un dialogue croissant entre préfet
et procureur il est nécessaire pour
assurer la bonne déclinaison
territoriale de la mise en oeuvre de la
politique pénale par l'autorité
judiciaire s'agissant du libre choix du
service enquêteur vous savez que ça a
été aussi un sujet d'inquiétude des
magistrats c'est une exigence de
l'article 12-1 du code de procédure
pénale
ce principe sort déjà certains endroits
aux capacités de traitement qui sont
limitées dans certains services
spécialisés c'est donc en fait
l'affectation et la répartition dans le
temps des moyens humains entre les
différents services d'un vecteurs qui
doit être en jeu c'est l'objet de la
proposition numéro 28 celle récemment
évoqué c'est la Numéro 20 donc il nous
faut absolument avoir une visibilité des
moyens des différents services à la fois
humains et même techniques pour ces
investigations on propose donc de
renforcer l'effectivité de ce principe
par plusieurs moyens un maintien des
moyens matériels et humains affectés aux
missions police judiciaires en
inscrivant dans les textes
réglementaires qui vont être nombreux
l'intégralité des services que
l'autorité judiciaire pourra servir dans
la nouvelle organisation de la police
nationale c'est d'ailleurs une
recommandation dans une certaine
d'ailleurs sont communes avec les audits
mais c'en est une et en prévoyant
notamment l'information systématique du
procureur et du juge d'instruction des
moyens qui vont être alloués à l'enquête
nous nous demandons aussi que les
doctrines qui sont actuellement
nationale en cours d'élaboration
rappelle formellement et solennellement
les grands principes des relations entre
l'autorité judiciaire et les services de
la spolis judiciaire c'est la
proposition numéro 22 je rappelle ces
principes le placement de la police
judiciaire sous la direction le contrôle
et la surveillance de l'autorité
judiciaire qui avaient leur
constitutionnelle les prérogatives de
l'autorité judiciaire s'agissant
notamment de la mise en oeuvre des
priorités de politiques pénales le
secret de l'instruction le secret de
l'enquête la préservation de la
possibilité pour le procureur ou le juge
d'instruction en fonction de l'avancée
de l'enquête de choisir librement le
service d'enquête en charge des
investigations la préservation également
d'une capacité à lutter contre
l'ensemble du spectre
depuis la criminalité organisée ou
financière à l'aide délinquance du
quotidien en passant et ça ça a été dit
et nous avons pu l'entendre souvent par
la délinquance intermédiaire en
présentant un ancrage inter
départemental et d'où le besoin aussi de
ce niveau intermédiaire pour tout pour
toute cette délinquance qui on appelle
plutôt le spectre 2 de notre délinquance
actuellement voilà les grands principes
qui devraient aussi donc être rappelé
afin de permettre une meilleure
un meilleur dialecte une meilleure
fluidité entre les services de
l'autorité judiciaire et de la police
judiciaire voilà en quelques mots les
principales recommandations que nous
avons pu faire quasiment de cette
mission avec mon collègue
et nous sommes à votre écoute si vous
avez des questions
ou pas enfin bref à l'écoute même si
vous n'avez pas de question
on m'entend Fabien Lebeau pour
Libération dans la proposition 21 au
quatrièmement vous évoquez une
obligation
instaurer une obligation du chef de
filière d'investigation et du directeur
départemental de la police nationale de
rendre compte au procureur de l'état des
procédures et l'état d'avancement de
certaines enquêtes est-ce que c'est une
telle obligation emporte pas le fait que
du coup les ddpn ou des DPN devront être
informés eux-mêmes par les effectifs de
l'avancée de toutes les enquêtes sur
leur ressorts vous voyez ce que je veux
dire vous voulez dire que le fait qu'il
nous l'idée c'est d'instaurer un
dialogue constant et croissant entre à
la fois les préfets les procureurs
d'accord et donc c'est à l'heure
actuelle dans la vie au quotidien il y a
ces rencontres et ses échanges mais on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas systématique et ça n'est pas
forcément aussi fluide que ça vous votre
inquiétude c'est de dire et bien si on a
un tort ce dialogue voilà on on pourrait
mettre en danger peut-être de
l'instruction ou du secret c'est pour ça
qu'on dit qu'il faut aussi rappeler que
le directeur départemental soit informé
des choses qui peuvent se passer sur son
territoire et que sur sa voie publique
il y est des policiers et qu'il y ait
des besoins ça semble tout à fait normal
et qu'il puisse y avoir un rappel aussi
en effet du secret de l'instruction et
du secret de l'enquête ça combine aussi
cette proposition mais nous nous disons
qu'on a on a pu constater que par
certains dans certains endroits ça
marche ça marche plutôt bien dans
d'autres c'est plus compliqué et notre
idée à nous c'est de pouvoir dire mais
voilà vous devez avoir un rendez-vous
pour vous parler en revanche on sait
très bien que si vous voulez il n'y a
pas on n'a pas senti
enfin en tout cas de tout ce que l'on a
pu entendre n'est pas revenu
l'inquiétude que si le directeur
départemental était au fait de
situations et que le préfet pouvait
l'être à ce moment-là il pourrait y
avoir une forme d'ingérence ou de alors
ça il faut le dire parce que la question
a souvent été posée par nous-mêmes
souvent par Jérôme et il n'y a pas eu
cette cette approche il y a pas eu cette
réaction à la fois on peut le dire des
magistrats des policiers Jérôme si tu
veux compléter c'était je pense que tu
es tout dit bon on rappelle parfois dans
certaines propositions des choses qui
devraient exister et qui existent déjà
en l'espèce sont déjà les supérieurs
hiérarchiques des services d'enquête et
donc on peut avoir un échange avec le
procureur mais Nadine et l'a très bien
dit
la nécessité c'est de garder le secret
de l'enquête et d'ailleurs on a été
interpellé localement parfois dans nos
déplacements ou à la faveur de de table
ronde sur le fait que cette tutelle
préfectorale pourrait un peu affaiblir
ce secret parce que c'est pas les mêmes
modalités parce que la police judiciaire
a une culture de préservation du secret
de l'enquête de l'instruction qui
voilà pourrait se déliter ou se diluer à
la faveur d'une nouvelle organisation
donc ce qu'on rappelle là c'est c'est
les règles et c'est les principes
merci
bonjour Emmanuel Leclerc France Inter
quand vous dit dans vos proposition une
organisation territorielle permettant de
traiter l'ensemble du spectre de la
criminalité à quel échelons vous le
placez du coup puisque là vous maintenez
que au niveau départemental il y a pas
forcément d'incompatibilité avec le
l'échelon préfectoral là du coup c'est
pour la police judiciaire vous le placez
à quel niveau puisque c'est tout l'enjeu
du débat depuis des mois et des mois
maintenant à tous les niveaux
au niveau le plus large et d'ailleurs on
le dit dans plusieurs propositions
les deux craintes exprimées assez
fortement au début de la présentation de
la réforme
c'est contrôle politique par le préfet
je fais cours je fais un peu caricatural
et l'enfermement
départemental et nous on oppose à
l'enfermement dans le départemental ou à
une forme de rigidité d'une carte
départementale une fluidité qui va du
département à la zone aux offices avec
les moyens dédiés partout de façon à ce
qu'on puisse répondre
aux besoins spécifiques de la police
judiciaire si la police judiciaire déjà
à l'époque de la Réforme joque c'était
un peu mis à part c'est parce qu'il y a
des sujets sur particulières c'est parce
qu'il y a des contraintes particulières
c'est parce qu'il y a des besoins
d'investigation et d'enquête
particuliers donc du coup on doit garder
cette fluidité pour la PJ à tous les
niveaux et la crainte de la disparition
de l'échelonale a été des manifestations
les plus importantes donc nous dans les
propositions qu'on fait qu'on voulait
reprendrez vous verrez que on insiste
sur le les moyens dédiés à tous les
échelons des moyens d'ailleurs des
offices à l'échelon zonal de façon à ce
qu'on garantit cette fluidité
territoriale et qu'on n'est pas une
rigidité qui empêche la Belgique
travailler sur de l'interdépartemental
de l'International de l'intérêt général
alors même que c'était le sens des
réformes conduites il y a quelques
années
c'est dit dans une des propositions
qu'on a formulé c'est l'heure qu'il peut
y avoir une il y a cette nécessité
d'avoir le hiérarchique et l'autorité
fonctionnelle et que le zonal a sa
comment dire sa dimension opérationnelle
a assumer
oui en fait il faut que on puisse
permettre à la police judiciaire de
s'exercer sur tous les champs de sur
tous les territoires donc lorsque vous
avez une criminalité qu'on peut
qualifier de petites et moyennes
délinquance évidemment l'échelon
départemental semble adapter très vite
on nous a dit d'ailleurs c'était ce qui
a fait que la police judiciaire c'est
ces manifesté délai tes derniers de dire
à ce moment-là il faut que la police
judiciaire soit entre guillemets
extraite on va dire mais on ne peut pas
l'extraire une réforme elle est globale
c'est la police nationale donc on peut
pas la sortir totalement du dispositif
mais en tout cas qu'il faut qu'il faille
réfléchir à son avenir de la poulie
judiciaire dans cette réforme de la
police nationale et en effet l'un il y a
eu une réflexion et il y a aussi c'est
pour ça qu'on vit dans une vous avez
bien raison de le souligner nous on dit
il faut que vous soyez très clair sur
cette dichotomie entre le fait qu'il y a
un directeur départemental qui aura de
façon opérationnelle la situation et
zona d'un point de vue hiérarchique donc
si vous voulez nous ce que l'on dit
c'est que il faut que soit le plus
adapté
la police judiciaire sur son territoire
et je vous rappelle que c'est pour ça
qu'aussi on veut instaurer un vrai
dialogue entre entre tous parce que il
revient soit au procureur soit au juge
d'instruction en fonction de l'avancée
du de l'instruction voilà il revient en
fait au magistrat de décider de quelle
de quelle police judiciaire on va
souhaiter c'est à dire est-ce qu'on l'a
on se dit on est sur un département
est-ce qu'on est interdépartemental ou
alors est-ce qu'on est à ce moment là au
niveau zonal voilà non mais c'est
certain mais il faudra il faut en effet
très bien clarifier les choses mais on
ne peut pas se dire qu'elle restera
qu'au niveau départemental il faut
qu'elle est la possibilité qui est la
possibilité pour les magistrats de
saisir d'avoir des enquêteurs sur des
criminalités qui sont de suite
évidemment qui sont en dehors des
frontières départementales bien sûr
c'est pas notre effort
donc l'exécutif le ministre de
l'Intérieur choisi de faire une réforme
une des formes départementalisation sur
laquelle d'ailleurs on avait peut-être
pas le même avis l'un et l'autre au
début et sur lequel notre avis est
peut-être pu changer depuis chacun mais
en l'état actuel des choses avec la
proposition de départementalisation il
nous semble que cette hiérarchisation et
cette organisation en plusieurs niveaux
de territoire peut permettre de
s'accommoder de la déportementalisation
après moratoire peut donner du temps
pour réfléchir à tout ça bien plus
utilement que ce qu'on a vu jusque là et
c'est pour ça que
on dit bien qu'il revient aussi au
ministre de l'Intérieur de bien
clarifier ensuite dans les textes et les
nombres décrets parce que vous savez que
parfois c'est souvent dans le décret que
se coucher des subtilités d'une réforme
et donc que dans les décrets il puisse
être clairement indiqué à la fois les
moyens à la fois les services et
également cette cette dichotomie qui
peut exister et quel sera exactement
cette répartition c'est en effet comme
l'ajustement dit Jérôme nous on a appelé
l'attention du gouvernement et du
ministre de l'Intérieur sur à la fois le
constat qui est partagé et sur à la fois
des propositions ou en tout cas alerter
sur ce qui peut poser de difficultés
d'où l'intérêt aussi et on insiste
dessus c'est que si vous voulez ce n'est
pas une réforme où l'on dit que cette
réforme doit être stoppée il faut tout
revoir nous on dit ce qui existe on le
prend on fait un état des lieux et à ce
moment là on a cette chance d'avoir
commencé dans huit départements une une
mise une mise en oeuvre enfin une
expérimentation c'est pas une mise en
oeuvre et qu'à ce moment là ça soit
vraiment de l'expérience cette
expérimentation devient une
préfiguration parce que vous aurez à
échelle réelle en ne gardant pas des à
droit constant les moyens parce que ça
ça a été un vrai sujet on a bien vu il y
avait de la bonne volonté pour certains
pour d'autres moins mais en tout cas il
y avait de la bonne volonté pour un
grand nombre d'entre eux mais avec des
moyens constants vous n'êtes pas dans le
même milieu vous n'avez pas mis
Informatique vous avez pas vous voyez il
y a une organisation tout ça c'est c'est
certainement et on pense que c'est Tony
opportunité attention il faut bien le
rappeler mais nous on dit aujourd'hui
pour donner sa chance à cette réforme il
faut que l'on soit en capacité d'en
faire après avoir fait son constat d'en
faire comment dire le mettre en oeuvre
de façon réelle et il y a eu des
départements aujourd'hui qui ont
commencé à travailler certains sont un
peu arrêtés parce que ils attendent
d'avoir un peu plus d'éclairage du côté
du ministre de l'intérieur mais
aujourd'hui à ce moment là et bien
allons allons-y dans ces départements
mais en ayant aussi en tête les
éclairages et les constatations et
surtout les préconisations que nous que
nous pouvons faire pour cette réforme
dernier mot peut-être sur ce point je
vous renvoie au
préconisations aux propositions 4 à 8
conformes dans la première partie et
j'insiste sur un point c'est le
fait que cette fluidité entre les
différents niveaux départements
interdépartements zone Office elle
permet aussi de répondre à une crainte
politique qui a été formulée
sur les attentats probabilités les
affaires sensibles l'idée qu'on puisse
avoir
tu m'excuseras la formule un dépaysement
au niveau zonal parce que on a un petit
peu de de vue d'avion et de vue
distanciée des sujets et tu aussi une
réponse à ce sujet positif
dû être dans des différentes dans les
différents rapports ça a été d'ailleurs
souligné et je crois que le ministre de
l'Intérieur
convenait éventuellement un dépaysement
pouvait être une solution
devant certaines inquiétudes
d'autres questions
on est passionné oui alors voilà
oui le président maintenant merci et le
président
qui a été fait n'est pas un rapport qui
par principe est hostile à la réforme il
est même plutôt favorable à la réforme
la question c'est de lui donner tous ces
chances d'aboutir pour avoir un outil
qui fonctionne qui à la fois fonctionne
dans son organisation et qui rassure
également quant à la au pouvoir
judiciaire et singulièrement procure la
République il reste les maîtres la
procédure ça c'est absolument essentiel
donc les propositions qui sont faites
sont aussi la promotion notamment de
moratoire c'est-à-dire on dit on lève le
pied pendant quelques temps on évite de
tout modifier pendant la période un peu
compliquée des Jeux Olympiques sur la
sécurité on sait que c'est un enjeu donc
on se donne ce temps-là et par ailleurs
on préfigure c'est à dire qu'on va
au-delà de la simple expérimentation on
préfigure c'est-à-dire qu'on met en
place véritablement le dispositif sur
les territoires évidemment déterminés
pour s'assurer que tout ça fonctionne
donc voilà la position telle qu'elle a
été du Sénat et de la commission des
lois en particulier sur ce point c'est
donc je pense que ce n'était pas inutile
le contraire que nous ayons mené mené ce
travail il se différencie un peu de
celui des autres mais ça c'est tant
mieux c'est un peu la spécificité de la
maison mais en l'occurrence
il veut donner sa chance et Nadine tout
à l'heure de laisser sa chance de la
réussite à ce texte enfin en tout cas
c'est très fort qui ne relève pas
d'ailleurs d'un texte législatif je le
rappelle qui est singulièrement
réglementaire et qui relève de
l'organisation interne d'un ministère
par le ministre quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs mais pour lequel le Parlement
a la circonstances c'est saisi de la
difficulté pour être incapacité de
proposer des choses voilà
devant vous sur la généralisation des
DPN à la fin de l'année
le ministre fera comme il le souhaitera
naturellement il a cette liberté là mais
je ne suis pas sûr que le Sénat est
toujours été de mauvais conseils sur
plusieurs textes récents on peut
considérer que d'ailleurs il a tenu
compte de ce que disait le scénariste
que proposait le singulièrement à la
commission des lois avec les collègues
et donc il je pense qu'il leur intérêt à
regarder ce qu'on a écrit
voilà merci à vous
excellente journée merci merci au
rapporteur surtout
merci à